what's happening in Washington certainly
we know happened in Austin Texas with
the state government years and years ago
and we had only hoped that that it
wouldn't happen in Washington there were
factors keeping it from from taking
place up there but in state government
in the state of Texas the lobby owns the
legislature nothing passes up there
unless the lobby wants it passed and and
that wasn't the case in Washington but
apparently that is the way Washington is
now what Grider's book has subtitled the
betrayal of American democracy what does
he mean by this well there's a lot of
talk about the beltway there's a lot of
talk about the insiders in Washington
and it's now becoming so obvious to
everybody that nobody plays the system
up there nobody is in the system except
those people that are around government
meaning the tremendous number of
lobbyists that are there now these are
the people that are controlling running
government these are the bag men that
that pay off the legislators the
congressmen and the Senators and in turn
get there they're enacted laws or kill
they're enacted laws and it's a
combination of of money and influence in
Washington that shuts out the rest of
the country meaning all the voters and
then what role do the two parties have
in this used to be that party's
represented grass roots from the top
from the bottom right up through the top
and then there can be some reflection of
this in policy or least attitudes on the
part of the Democrats but greater says
something different now has happened
real revolution well the the parties
don't mean anything of course in terms
of how they affect people and voters and
the public it seems to me that all all
they are anymore is the organization
that puts together the nominating group
and holds the convention and they
doesn't really have anything to do
anymore with who's elected the party
used to be the place where the nominees
for for the presidency were selected but
not anymore
Grider calls this mock democracy
well he calls it a lot of things it
calls it sudo he called the mock
democracy because the day after the
election the voters are put back in into
their boxes and they're not asked or
consulted again for four more years
right up at the front
Grider talks about something which
Americans consider a no-no particularly
the American press and even academia
that is class structure and class
conflict he says that there's an
American ruling class and that it is
taken over all of the power and the
American people are just completely shut
out this is and that elites are those
that are in the positions of power and
and regardless of which administration
is in this or which party you're talking
about that's right both parties are
indistinguishable in terms of the power
structure the payoffs the lobbies in
fact the lobby groups up there are all
mostly law firms and they have their
democratic people and they have their
Republican people and so they've
neutralized the whole party system by by
making no differentiation between
parties
Grider talks about the res section on
realities of power he uses the term
hollow or hollow laws and client ism
what does he mean by hollow laws well
this is a trick that our government
plays on us Democrats and Republicans
and that is they passed these laws that
are sham laws
I mean first place the teeth are all
pulled out of them but they they may
sound pretty good and then of course
once they pull the teeth out of them
they either don't fund the agencies
enough to see that the laws are carried
out or the agencies are are filled full
of people that make sure that they're
not that the intent isn't carried out or
they put people in the Supreme Court to
make sure that none of it works and so
the public has been told as they were
with tax reform hey we're going to make
these fat cats pay well they didn't they
made poor people pay more and let the
fat cats off even
more than they had been and in 81 83 86
all those so called were farm periods in
tax law
they were the public was told that the
public was going to benefit when it
there was never any attention to having
a public benefit and the public didn't
even know about it all they knew was
after a few years went by something was
wrong and something sure was wrong
had been lied to and and it was a sham
mock set of laws that were put on the
books and greater talks about random law
enforcement to where random law
enforcement of course is where selective
agencies pick the one that picked the
pieces of the law they want to enforce
or not enforce and essentially the law
enforcement is more or less left to
private groups who have an interest in
making sure that the law is enforced and
in there a section on corporate power
where it shows that the corporations
themselves are the biggest lawbreakers
in the country and even if they get
caught with their hand in the cookie jar
the most they ever get is a slap and on
the wrists and that doesn't hurt him at
all or they'll get a consent decree
where they didn't admit they did it but
they said they won't do it again
well that that's been the case for a
hundred years in this country
well since the corporations particularly
railroads became dominant and they in
turn made sure that the laws didn't
impact them very much they in turn made
sure that the laws weren't enforced that
had a very negative influence on them
and we had the antitrust laws that were
more or less meaningless except from a
few times to few times and Grider has a
whole chapter in here on on what he
calls citizen General Electric citizen
General Electric which is probably the
biggest law breaking corporation we've
ever seen it's over and over fined and
cited for for breaking laws and evading
laws it it has a whole lobby
it has a whole army of lobbyists in
Washington to make sure that the laws
that are passed
are favorable to it and so General
Electric has the benefit of being
treated as a citizen as a private
citizen that's the way the law in this
country treats corporations and even if
these corporations are criminal they're
not treated like criminal people and
stripped of certain rights they're
allowed on the one hand to pay many
school fines and then go ahead and
contract with the government to screw
the government like they had been doing
in the past or to break the laws again
meanwhile the people who should be
responsible the chief executives or the
people on the Board of Directors got a
free ride and are off scot-free well
that's right and once in a while they'll
convict or they'll charge a corporate
officer with some wrongdoing when it was
so egregious that they can't can't avoid
it but they've been very few of General
Electric people treated like that
and that's what it takes they're going
to throw some of these GE people in the
slammer so they'll take some of the law
seriously that they're breaking what
those writers say about the performance
of the media well the media of course is
a business and they then you begin to
look at it in terms of the same
attitudes that that other businesses
have and that is to to make sure that
the corporate world is dominant to make
sure the business world is dominant to
repress workers and eliminate unions and
it it also has concentration of course
the concentration the media means that
there's less diversity and even even
more ominous is the fact for example
that citizen General Electric owns the
NBC network and there's not any way the
NBC network is there ever going to say
anything adverse to citizen General
Electric or the or the regular or the
interests that it has like the Kidder
Peabody and Wall Street firms it's got
it you can't even keep up with all the
interest that this conglomerate General
Electric has and all the interest around
the world that it has but and in
military spending and in military
contracting it just goes on and on what
role is there left for the people then
well every four years they get to rubber
stay
one of the other of Tweedledum or
Tweedledee it's as simple as that
and then the day after the election we
go back to to lobby practice and payoffs
and corruption and bribery as usual the
Grider talks about what's impudent -
what's this term impudent demonstrations
or something like that that's the only
role that people have they can get on
the regular media and so they have to go
out and sass cops or carry signs around
that's the only way they can try to get
their word across well they did they do
two things one is of course they they
developed a booming business out of talk
show hosts and the talk show hosts let
these people sound off and give their
opinions that can't be given any other
way and the other is some smart
entrepreneur picks it up sometime like
Ross Perot did in the in the last
election and sees what the concerns are
and begins to play on this sentiment
that somebody from the outside needs to
get in there and clean that mess up
Grider talks about a real revolution
where for the first time he says the
democrats and republicans are
collaborating now this is a point that
you alluded to a while ago that there
doesn't seem to be any friction among
the two it's just all one big smelly
slimy corrupt pot up there well of
course the the meeting point for that
for that slop jar is the lobbies in
Washington and of course the lobbies in
Washington are made up of law firms that
are that are Democrats and Republicans
and of course they've got their clients
and and the Democratic members of these
lobby groups hustle the Democratic
members of Congress and the Republican
members hustle the Republican Congress
and and they're all bribing them in
terms of PAC money and contributions and
it all turns out the same it's all it
all turns out the same way and it makes
no difference because what's driving the
process is money campaign contributions
I guess the most egregious example of
this corruption and how it goes
unpunished is the Savings and Loan
debacle well he grader uses the savings
alone a disaster as in effect that's
where he's tired will come from who will
tell the people he asked who told the
people that this mess was was a danger
and that this mess was starting and if
this mess was continuing and that this
mess was going to cost five hundred
billion dollars
nobody except alternative you that 20 in
Washington yes and not enough people are
seeing and watching prayer but nobody in
Washington and of course for example the
fact that that Republicans and Democrats
alike were implicated in this made money
off the same thing that that's that's
typical of the situation in which no
mention of this S&L scandal was brought
up in the election in 1988 why because
Lord Benson is tarred with this Lloyd
Bentsen very obviously made money out of
the SNL disaster and yet he was a vice
presidential candidate on Democratic
ticket in 1988 so he couldn't afford to
have it brought up so it wasn't brought
up and it's still not being brought up
and where is he going now to the
Treasury Department and who was there
when the mess took place James Baker and
both of those people were involved in
this disaster in Houston Texas in buying
and selling savings and loans to the
Mafia Jack what about foreign interests
we've talking about special interests in
the United States being so heavily Oprah
over represent Robert over represented
and so powerful in Washington
well those themed lobbies are just as
quick or maybe quicker to represent
foreign interests because there's more
there's probably more money in the
foreign interest and therefore foreign
governments Japanese and whoever else
you might want to talk about have better
access to our representatives and we do
a lot of the people on the Clinton staff
and the transition team directly
represent foreign interests even though
he said he was he
criticize people for having foreign
interests so powerfully represented in
the Republican yeah and they weren't
they weren't exceptions I mean they they
were numerous they were so numerous that
it looks to me like it's clear that the
Clinton administration is going to be
business as usual it's all for sale well
the author of this who will tell the
people brighter talks about it's kind of
like the macro-level what has happened
as a result of all this and it's really
kind of scary he says national
sovereignty is going down the tube
prosperity has gone for most of us the
middle class is wiped out and social
Amity is gone the social contract is
fading and it's fading because the
corporate interests seem to think that
that they can just kill the the social
agreement that they had between the
corporate management the workers the
consumers of the products and the
stockholders we had we had to some
extent a a social fabric that included
all those people and the ones who
weren't even in the corporation for
years we thought that who lived in this
country had a stake in this country but
now it's clear that if you don't have
some kind of special stake that the that
the International corporation wants or
can use you've got no stake anywhere and
your wages are going to go down your
your benefits are going to go down your
job possibility they're going to go down
and the International Corporation
doesn't think it has any responsibility
and of course it it may very well less
than that responsibility with these
trade agreements old guys does these
trade agreements are going to make sure
that they determined what it is they
want to provide wherever they are and
regardless of what people at the local
state or national levels even want
that's right and it problem is going to
be that once you get locked into a trade
agreement then the trade agreement is
too big and can be made up is too
important for any one piece of it to be
evaded
and we've already seen that in the in
the Republican administration and also
in the attitudes and and some of the
speeches and remarks of the Clinton
people also well the scary part is that
that covered covered over with this
whole attitude of tariffs and quotas and
the usual trade barriers is the non
trade barriers I mean it's been a very
slick ploy to hide these non trade
barriers which are nothing more than a
visions of certain kinds of corporate
requirements and regulations such as
Clean Air Act's and other kinds of
environmental arrangements and safety
requirements for labor these these are
all designed to be eliminated if the
corporation wants to eliminate it in the
graters chapter on class conflict he
talks about how the American people are
very uncomfortable talking about class
structure and their place in it
well there's a lot of research on the
the class system in this country and and
and I've read a lot of it and it it kind
of boils down to the question of of not
class systems but status and what
indicates status and what do people
think about status and never gets down
to the question of the power and the
money elite in this country squashing
the rest of us
it never gets down to that and it also
gets clouded up with a notion of well
implicit in this is unionism and of
course we hate unions because unions are
somehow by definition bad and therefore
we want to be associated with them
therefore that's a class and we just
don't even consider a possibility of a
class structure being in place and they
foment class divisions in class hatred
remember during this election every time
that one of the candidates particularly
Democratic candidate who is opposing
Clinton for the nomination every time
they'd say something about how the
people got screwed and just a lot of
things we find in Grider's book the
media would immediately jump on him and
say oh he's fomenting class hatred I saw
that all throughout the media
once again the the media itself is part
of the problem and the media is just one
reason we're having all these these
concerns and these lakhs of
responsibilities in the government mass
communication is grown and proliferated
we've had a concentration of the media
themselves we've had a growth in the
expertise business the experts are the
only ones that know anything because
everything is too complicated for the
rest of us dumb people and the think
tanks the Heritage Foundation the Cato
foundation the American Enterprise
Corporation the Manhattan Institute all
these so-called expert think tanks are
are paid for and bought by the corporate
and the power system and in effect the
the opinions they deliver in terms of
expertise always support the power
system and nothing else really is up for
argument because there aren't any other
system there aren't any other experts
out there countering them hardly so the
people who are the power elite doing the
work for the ruling class they set the
agenda for what you see on the media
what you are taught in school what their
where philanthropy money will go for the
whole thing it's all one big system
until the American people realize this
and face up to it they're not even going
to know what to oppose much less be
successful in struggling to make any
change well there was a time there of
course when those kinds of pseudo
agencies expert agencies didn't exist
and the two-party system kind of argued
amongst themselves and they were they
had differences but the two-party system
doesn't have any meaning anymore so it's
gone it's no longer a place that people
can can expect some kind of reaction and
and then last of course in all these
problems that are that are getting us to
this place where we're not represented
and not paying attention to is the
so-called global economy in which
everything is in terms of Oh
well we've got to compete with all those
foreigners so you got to get out of our
way and let us do what we want to do the
way we want to do it free trade that's
Shibboleth free trade well Grider calls
this the closet dictator the closet
dictator is the global economy and you
always point to him is not letting you
do things that you would do if you had
to and of course meaning you would allow
democracy to operate in this country but
that old that old devil global economy
won't let you there's a real good book
which I'm sure you read called global
reach which came out in the 70s I guess
it was early 70s talking about how the
multinational corporations work and how
they control things and how they have
the people who run these corporations
are strictly global they have they have
no loyalty to any government or any
people in any nation but they require
absolute and national loyalty from the
rest of us when we are supposed to fight
their Wars or other things like this but
now the global economy instead of having
multinational corporations with plants
in one country and doing their trade now
it is a truly global factory where
portions of certain segments of the
production of a product are made in
different countries and then they're put
together it's been a revolution in that
aspect half of the Ford the
american-made Ford automobile is made in
Japan and the parts are shipped over
here and put together over here same is
true the Toyota there's there's hardly
any difference between the Toyota and
the manufacturing of a Toyota in this
country and the Ford in this country
they're made from Japanese parts they
were shipped over here meanwhile the
American car manufacturers have large
investments in Japanese car
manufacturing companies most people
don't realize that but there's this book
called the work of nations by
rike and he talks about how this has
become so atomized and where you have
say for instance the in one country
they'll come up with a computer program
and then they'll have another country
enter it after all this information into
the various computer software and then
it's shipped somewhere else where the
the chips which are manufacturing in
another country come in and then it's
assembled in another country so national
boundaries mean absolutely nothing
anymore well they certainly don't in
terms of where the jobs flow to because
they they may be in one country for two
or three years and move on to another
country for another two or three years
and of course manufacturing is the
high-paying jobs and when the
manufacturing jobs go there nothing left
with service jobs and service jobs not
only are they non-union but they
generate a low skill and therefore low
paying writer talks about a frightening
aspect of this and he says that the
global economic order is producing
global feudalism he as he calls it a
form of feudalism because it's in effect
nobody has any rights nobody but the
very most powerful organizations and
groups have any rights everybody else
doesn't have any rights and working at
semi-starvation wages what if they've
got a benefits and of course the the
unions don't have any chance at all to
get organized in a situation like this
and this is the aim the aim is is to let
the the corporation citizen General
Electric do what he wants to do when he
wants to do it the way it wants to
whether it's a good idea or not I mean
the man that runs General Electric is
just another corporate flunky that rose
up through the ranks by brown-nosing and
who knows if the man really has any
ability other than to figure out some
way maybe to monopolize a trade and to
make quarterly higher quarterly profits
but that's got nothing to do with with
the interest of the United States hardly
and certainly not in terms of a
political
that might be made by General Electric
and they're made all the time I think we
should mention that this what we're
talking about is not just something that
was hatched up during the reagan-bush
years but you see the seats of a going
way back to the American Revolution
where the group of people who were in
the Continental Congress and who signed
the Declaration of Independence were
different people from those who sat in
sealed secrecy in Philadelphia who were
drafting the Constitution in the United
States and because there was a
tremendous class struggle at that time
when the people in the in Philadelphia
tried to get the Constitution passed and
they themselves said that the main thing
they were trying to do with her
Constitution was to protect their
property and their power from the
unwashed public it was very obvious in
what they said in the Federalist Papers
they said that it was an economic doc
document and they wanted to produce
enough flaws so that the ordinary common
people wouldn't be able to get their
hands on the levers of power
and you see this happening all
throughout American history and even
coming down until the great debate of
the the 60s and early 70s of the crisis
of democracy where the people in power
the book of the trilateral commission
said that democracy and capitalism are
antithetical you can't have them
existing and people have to accept a
lesson role people can't make any
demands on the system that the
capitalists have to be in complete
control so you see this going all
throughout American history and we're
really seeing it now well we we had an
example of this after World War one when
the business interest took over the
country and ran it into the ground and I
thought we learned by then that you
can't afford even even if these people
weren't mostly or largely are to some
extent corrupt they certainly are mostly
or partly or to some extent incompetent
and the combination is such that we
can't have these people running things
all the time but that that's what we've
got what I haven't been very much of a
conspiracy
theorist but I see a I see a conspiracy
here I see I see the goals and the means
and the intent and I see the people
doing it I see grinder lays it out in
effect router has here a conspiracy
theory in which the public will lose its
power and those people with money at an
oligarchy is going to take over it's
taken over in fact it's just a matter of
whether it can be restored or not he
thinks it can be he thinks democracy can
be restored from the oligarchy it's
turned into that's that's certainly
questionable well how does how does he
say this is going to happen well I'm
going to raise up in their wrath and
throw the rascals out he he doesn't
exactly say that here is a way to throw
the rascals out I mean he thinks out
like no girls you I guess down bad yet
he's a graduates kind of guy he says
first you got a research of faith in
democratic society Oh real search your
faith then you got to become skeptical
he he makes the point that most most
Americans are a lot of Americans are
pretty tied to Authority whatever
Authority says that's what you expect
that's what you you come to think is
correct and that's been that's been the
case saying we we certainly need to get
away from that and I think I think that
may be a fact we're becoming less so
then we need to have more local
organization and more political
involvement at the local our local
levels and and of course the idea being
that once you become active politically
locally that somehow spreads
I mean how it's going to spread it isn't
clear but that's the that's the theory
and then finally you just have to rebel
against powerlessness because that's
what we're talking about the public is
powerless it has no no power and you
have to rebel against that well hey if
you take that literally a rebellion
means you got to get tough and he
doesn't talk very much about that and
how tough you're going to get you know
you just may have to come to push and
shove and people may have to go beyond
what is thought of as normal bounds